dude oh my god is that Keanu Reeves
dude that's Keanu Reeves that's great
you need to get his autograph no I'm Way
too embarrassed I'm not gonna oh come on
you'll be the one there's he's the
nicest guy dude come on mr. Reeves I'm
gonna do for you guys
Keanu right um is it cool if I maybe you
get your autograph
absolutely I'd be honored yes all right
thank you so much what's your name
I'm called Sam do we come on account of
your focus back whoa back up
chill it's chill generous I hate to
intrude what looks like you're
struggling look look
whatever's in the register I'll triple
and then I'll match that to a charity of
your choice
we'll do that absolutely I'd rather give
are you guys point your guns at me
instead there's no way we can
communicate effectively when you have
guns pointed at each other's heads right
now let's just all take a deep breath
together
I rode my bike here man
okay I know the cops listen you can take
my 1970 Ford Mustang from John wick you
can outrun the cops in it I'll walk home
and it's a win-win trust I can't believe
how nice yes sir just a car
[Applause]
you hear me look let me be your hostage
what the morning [ __ ] okay Gianna mates
just take the gonna put it to my head
what let him go Sammy go yes and you can
put me in the audience don't you it's
okay we'll make more money this what
sorry about that
so Sam right yeah
do you still not want your car yeah
thank you so much for taking time out of
your busy schedule to goober out of us
for one day it was awesome you guys are
phenomenal your breath take your breath
take yeah whoa listen I put together a
very special playlist for everyone to
check out of corridor film videos you
just have to make sure you subscribe and
then hit the bell button to get all the
notifications for all the awesome videos
to come
alright guys there's a link in the
description to Kiana's playlist check it
out it's the best videos of ours that he
liked alright pleasure it's been a real
pleasure thank you